proof global food inequality well
british scientists have succeeded in
creating tomatoes rich in vitamin d
using a process called gene editing and
it's thought the breakthrough will lead
to the possibility of lessening the
negative impact conventional farming has
on the environment
sky science correspondent tom clark has
been to meet those working on a trial in
norwich
they don't look any different to
ordinary tomatoes which is very much the
point but these have been genetically
edited to produce high levels of vitamin
d
normal tomatoes like most fruit and veg
contain virtually none but just one of
these has as much vitamin d as two eggs
or a serving of tuna
they used a gene editing technique
called crispr cast 9 to tweak the
tomatoes dna we talk about genetic
tweezers
it really is very very small
nature equivalence it can happen
naturally or it could happen naturally
but the amount of work and time
required to make that change and then to
select it and breed it in
is
prohibitively long
the technique is fundamentally different
to previous incarnations of genetic
modification or gm
most gm products contain genes from
another organism that confer a benefit
a type of gm cotton for example has a
gene from a bacterium to make it
resistant to insect pests
by contrast gene editing inserts
molecular machinery borrowed from
bacteria to delete swap or repeat genes
already in the plant's genetic code
before removing the foreign dna
afterwards
the difference is a crucial one because
this week the government will put
forward a bill making it much easier to
bring gene-edited crops to market
and they're closer than you might think
this plot is the first crop of
gene-edited wheat growing anywhere
outdoors in europe and the researchers
behind it hope that this change in the
law will be the first step to taking
crops like this out of field trials and
seeing them benefit society it's the
first positive step in crop
biotechnology regulation
in europe or the uk for
a generation 25 years
and
i've suffered all through that
period we've been waiting for this for a
long time and i think
it's really a positive step
this wheat has been edited to make less
of the cancer-causing compound
acrylamide when it's fried but
researchers are also looking at editing
out common wheat allergens or making the
crop more drought or pest resistant it's
really important that we don't miss out
on the next biotech revolution which is
gene editing and that is already off and
running in some parts of the world
united states for example several years
canada brazil
argentina just this year we see china
and india moving on on biotech
on gene editing so
really important that we keep up but
opponents of gene editing dispute
claimed similarities to traditional
breeding and say the law change is a
step towards more elaborate genetic
engineering it's entirely misleading to
say that gene editing doesn't involve
the insertion of foreign genes
in fact gene editing is
a suite of technologies that range from
a simple snip to the complex insertion
of foreign genes
and the traits that get scientists
really excited things like disease
resistance and drought resistance simply
cannot be achieved without these complex
technological interventions with gene
editing scientists have proven they got
a tool that could revolutionize food and
farming but they have some way to go to
prove real benefits to society and the
environment
tom clark sky news norwich
well good growing weather at the moment
uh let's have a look at the forecast
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
and a active jet stream will steer
cooler wetter and windier weather this
way over the course of the week however
there'll be some brighter spells around
as well and it could settle down for the
weekend
but right now eastern parts of england
the rain will clear to the north sea
this evening but there'll be some
showers elsewhere
well now health experts say that monkey
pox only poses a very low threat and is
not likely to bring disruption like
kobit 19. it is though being recommended
that contacts of monkey pox should
self-isolate for 21 days according to
latest government guidance meanwhile
after recent cases were identified among
gay and bisexual men the united nations
aids agency has called some reporting
about the virus racist and homophobic
warning of exacerbating stigma and
undermining the response to the outbreak
when all day you've been sending us your
questions and we'll do our best to
answer them right now joining us is
oxana pizzic global health advisor and
lecturer at ucl school of pharmacy and
dr mark laughton consultant in sexual
health and hiv and clinical lead at the
liverpool center for sexual health a
very good evening to you both thank you
very much indeed for joining us for this
uh important question and answer session
we're going to dive straight into our
viewers questions we've had so many of
them and uh let's ask the first one
which so many people are thinking about
it's really three questions and we'll
take it uh in parts first up then asks
how serious is it uh why has it been
spreading so fast and how likely is it
that we will have a lockdown for it well
let's break that up then um how serious
is it uh what do you think oxana
well all of the cases reported so far
have been mild uh there have been no
deaths and and no people have required
uh hospitalizations that being said uh
in the areas where it is endemic uh
mostly in african countries uh there are
people have died and there is an
estimate mortality rate
between three to six percent
this is a rough estimate the
surveillance of that data is flawed
and also we do know that in a lot of
these areas there are also other health
problems and
that means that people who already have
underlying health conditions and
children are more vulnerable
but what we are seeing is very atypical
we don't tend to see it outside of areas
that are endemic um for example nigeria
etc so in in the cases that we have seen
outside of africa there have been all
mild cases okay uh dr lawton then um
uncomfortable but not too threatening
yeah i think so i think um you know the
the second part of that question why is
it spreading so fast um maybe it is but
maybe we're just recognizing it and and
people are coming forward getting tested
so that we're seeing the cases um i
think that may be part of the the
jumping numbers that have been reported
in the last uh you know week or so
yeah i mean oxalic i mean is it the fact
that there's media attention on this i
mean 57 cases i mean it's a statistical
blip in a nation of 65 million people is
it actually spreading fast
well i i think again the reason is
cotter that this is not a new virus uh
as we said monkey pox is something that
uh was was discovered decades ago
the reason it has so much meat attention
is because it hasn't been identified in
this setting uh it hasn't been spreading
in high-income countries i think that's
taken a lot of experts by surprise so
there is an element of we are trying to
understand if it is possible for the
transmission
method to have uh slightly changed uh
monkey pox belongs to ortho pox viruses
so this is in the family of chickenpox
smallpox um and they tend to be really
stable viruses they don't tend to mutate
so much so very different situation to
what we see with coronaviruses which
have a very long genome they lots of
replication errors lots of mutations um
people have lost track almost of the
number of different variants so yeah
it's definitely not the same level of
spread for sure but there could be
something different we don't know yet i
think it's important to say that
there are lessons being learned right
now um because it is unusual to see it
in these other environments but it could
also be as we heard from our other
panelists
that our surveillance systems are just
much more highly attuned postcode yeah i
mean that is the point dr lawton isn't
it i mean it is postcode well it's still
during kobe everyone's still on high
alert and uh that third part of the
question that's what people are thinking
about how likely is it we'd have a
lockdown for it and in actual fact even
if it did start spreading massively
would a lockdown work in in these cases
well i think you're right i think people
are very aware of of covid and suddenly
every cough and cold that we have people
have become aware of that perhaps we
weren't before um and also what we've
become is much more conscious of the
potential infectivity of coughs and
colds and maybe not gone into work where
we would have done before covid so i
think that certainly has had some impact
on behavior i think with monkey pox it's
very unlikely we're going to get to a
situation where we would have a lockdown
um you know this is a virus that's
spread um through close contact mostly
sort of skin to skin can be through
infected um clothes or bed linens and
potentially droplets from you know close
contact um so i think it's unlikely that
it's gonna spread perhaps in the same
way in that you know arenas or wherever
we may have had some of the initial
problems with covid so i think i think
that's unlikely i mean ultimately still
very very rare
most people will have a very mild
illness so um part of the reasons for
lockdown with covid was the fact it was
going to overwhelm the health service we
don't expect to see that kind of um
problem problem with monkey pox so yeah
i think i think we can be reasonably
comfortable at the moment i'm going to
stay with you dr lawton now for our next
question because it's clearly in your
field of expertise it's from siobhan and
asks has it only spread through sexual
contact that's because a large
proportion of the cases detected so far
in the uk have been uh through uh
homosexual bisexual and men who have um
sex with other men is it though i mean
it clearly is close contact but is it
only spread through sexual contact
no absolutely not and i think it's
important that we don't sort of label
this as a sexually transmitted infection
it's transmitted through sexual contact
of sorry close contact of any sorts now
obviously sexual contact might mean
that's that that close contact is closer
it might mean that contact is is for
longer periods of time um and you know
sex is very popular and so you know we
do see it spread in that in that
mechanism but it's certainly not a
sexually transmitted infection and i
think one of the problems that we still
have sadly in in this country is a lot
of stigma surrounding sexually
transmitted infections so it's important
that we don't introduce stigma because
that then becomes a barrier for people
coming forward and getting tested which
is what we need to do to try and
minimize the spread of this very good
point so you mentioned uh testing there
let's uh move on to my
next question not my next question the
viewers next question just asking well
vaccines of course forefront of people's
minds after the covet experience do we
have a a vaccine
for monkey pox oxana doesn't the the
smallpox vaccine have some role to play
here
yeah we have um several vaccines that
are available for the prevention of
smallpox these are old vaccines and they
do actually
also it was noted uh
decades ago that it also helped to
prevent monkey pox up to 85 percent
effective
in preventing monkey pox as well so
there is some cross benefit but of
course um here in the uk anyone who's
under 50 is very unlikely to be
vaccinated with smallpox because um that
was eradicated in the 80s and and the
vaccination program wrapped up around
them as well so um
there are newer vaccines available
since then but they are not widely
available so the w cho is working with
manufacturers to improve access for the
newer vaccines um but there is already
um historically um
some good protection provided by the
smallpox vaccine so does that mean dr
lawton that older people who've had the
smallpox vaccination until it was
eradicated i know that younger people
haven't because
it's gone but older people then are
pretty well
sorted i think we won't know necessarily
how effective that vaccine may be some
you know decades potentially after
people have had it um we know from other
vaccines such as covid that immunity can
wane over time and it may be that you
know there is some protection still and
down the line it may not be as effective
and also you know if there is close
contact and there's a recommendation of
vaccine i think we probably still
recommend people have that vaccine if
they've been in contact okay
i don't think it's going to be
completely universal okay
good points and plenty more to come from
you thank you very much indeed so far
we've got to take a short break do stay
with us after that break we're going to
be asking our panel more of those
questions about monkey pox and what can
be done to stop its spread
[Music]
welcome back we're answering your
questions about monkey box i've got
oksana perject with me global health
advisor and lecturer at ucl school of
pharmacy and dr mark lawton from the
liverpool center for sexual health so
let's crack on in the time available
this question from mallory how long can
monkeypox virus remain infectious on
items outside the body well how long or
can it at all oxana what's known about
it
well i again there's so much that is
still unknown uh it's not a very there
are areas around us that are not well
documented um and partly that has to do
with our investment on diseases that are
in low-income countries but we do know
that it can be infectious through
bedding
through clothing
again in close contact so while the
virus would not be viable for very long
the exact period again unknown
there is that risk of it being
transmitted through
fabrics
that have been
up against open sores lesions etc
okay um we are cracking through the
questions this next one
let's put this to you then mark with
chickenpox being rife amongst children
at the moment how can you tell the
difference between that and monkey pox
yeah what is the actual difference
so firstly i think we have to to just
point out that chicken pots is very
common and of course monkey pox is still
very very rare so it's far far more
likely that a child would have chicken
pox than monkey pox so a couple of key
differences i suppose will be worth sort
of pointing out with monkey pox we
sometimes see swollen glands as part of
that initial illness and that's quite
rare with chicken pox the other thing is
that monkey pox rash tends to occur sort
of all at once whereas chicken pox you
sort of keep getting new lesions coming
throughout the time course i think the
only time particularly to be concerned
in a young child might be is if there
has been contact with somebody who's
perhaps had foreign travel to some of
those areas such as western central
africa where monkey pox therefore
suddenly makes it more likely than
chickenpox but but otherwise i think
chickenpox is very common monkeypoxes
but is it actually worse monkeypox in
terms of how you feel
so i think both illnesses can be um you
know variable young children getting
chickenpox
often very very um mild or no symptoms
apart from itching from from from the
from the rash likewise with monkey pox
very small proportion of people can get
ill with monkey pox and still with young
children you know very
very small proportion could get ill from
chickenpox so the severity doesn't
necessarily dictate which is which
yeah and we've seen some of the the
pictures some pretty awful lesions and
so matthew asks this question oxana does
monkey pox scar is it a bit like those
of us that remember having chicken pox
and indeed measles back in the day if
you if you scratch the scab that's more
likely to cause a scar isn't it
uh yes so in more severe cases uh where
you have more severe lesions they can
also be um even on the palm of the hands
um that can cause scarring
particularly if the scabs are then
scratched so in more severe cases you do
see that these pustules after they scab
over um scratched they can leave
scarring but in milder cases less so and
i suppose we should have asked this
first but let's ask it last i think it's
all we're gonna have time for uh from
anthony why is it called monkey pox well
he kind of answered that already but uh
just be specific for us dr lorton
yeah so it was first discovered i think
in the 1950s amongst a colony of monkeys
um so that's where the monkey bit comes
from and pox just sort of means a spot
or a pustule these vehicles these this
rash that you get with monkey pox so
yeah monkeys first seen in monkeys pox
the spots or the pustules
yeah and uh so people worrying then
oxana that well you know coming from
monkeys it is this zoonotic spread again
isn't that what's causing quite a lot of
concern
well uh we do see that there is a
possibility that it does it's a zoonotic
illness so it does transfer um from
animals to humans but what we're seeing
um now is actually a human to human
community transmission um so it isn't uh
again in endemic regions we do see that
uh spillover uh but
currently the missing piece of puzzles
is why is it happening um in europe and
in the americas okay well uh help uh
thank you very much for helping us uh
examine that puzzle oksana persie dr
mark lorton very good talking to you
thank you very much indeed there we are
enlightened as much as we can be about
monkey pox